thanks to a loan scheme being pioneered
by british gymnastics these youngsters
in wakefield now have access to premium
facilities and qualified coaches
called club capital the program is
making 10 million pounds available for
new gymnastics centers to open up or for
existing ones to expand
as a sport we have huge demands um that
we're trying to meet and facilities and
clubs like this are helping us grow and
meet that that and obviously from a
sport as you can see in the background
we're predominantly a child young people
support and facilities and investing
into this enables to give those
fantastic opportunities and experiences
in keeping children young people
active doing
hands on your head if you know what
this facility doesn't just benefit the
budding gymnasts it's created jobs and
links to local schools and the wider
community
it's important to remember that this
isn't a grant it's a loan but without
the three 300 000 pounds utopia wouldn't
have been able to turn around the future
of this abandoned warehouse
it's difficult enough to start up a new
business at any time during a pandemic
it's even tougher it's been very
challenging and we've had a few setbacks
and delays however i think you know
there's
so we're the type of people in life that
will keep going and you know we really
believed in what we were doing we've
currently got over 500 members now we
offer various types of gymnastics
parties holiday camps and dance and even
cheerleading
for these five to eight-year-olds it's
just a lot of fun
i enjoy doing musical bumps and
stretching
and doing like um the backwards rolls
and front rows
i like being on the fast track and the
trampolines and jumping in the foam pit
i like coming here because the coaches
are really nice and i have a lot of fun
british gymnastics are also making one
and a half million pounds available in
the form of covid recovery loans for
existing clubs who may be struggling to
balance the books
fraser moored sky news wakefield